liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger es
sind bedrückende tage die wir gemeinsam
durchs leben
wenn wir morgens aufwachen dann erkennen
wir unsere welt zwar wieder aber sie
scheint doch seltsam unwirklich
die fußgängerzone ist verweist der
schulhof leer und still die stammkneipe
der lieblingsitaliener verrammelt die
wenigen fußgänger auf der straße machen
einen bogen um einander manche von uns
trifft die krise schon heute besonders
hart durch krankheit durch einsamkeit
oder durch wirtschaftliche sorgen viele
andere erleben diese tage eher als eine
art erzwungene entschleunigung wir sind
zur ruhe aufgerufen und spüren doch eine
innere unruhe
wir sollen geduld haben und suchen doch
ungeduldig nach normalität wir sollen
abstand halten und sehnen uns doch nach
nähe ja diese krise weckt unsere
tiefsten ängste aber sie ruft auch das
beste in uns hervor
daran liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
müssen wir uns jetzt halten
ich habe in den vergangenen tagen mit
menschen gesprochen die genau das
vorleben die mut machen und hilfe
leisten
der medizinstudent amanda grewal aus
reutlingen hat in windeseile eine online
plattform geschaffen die medizin
studierende an kliniken und praxen
vermittelt die krankenhausangestellte
kathrin höhne nett zu hause gemeinsam
mit ihren drei kindern schutzmasken für
ihre klinik der pianist igor levit
streamt abend für abend beglückende
musik aus seinem wohnzimmer in unsere
wohnzimmer
heute abend sendet er übrigens hier aus
dem schloss bellevue diese wenigen
beispiele zeigen wir sind vielleicht zur
isolation verdammt aber nicht
zur untätigkeit liebe mitbürgerinnen
mitbürger jeder und jede von ihnen kann
jetzt helfen mit dem einkauf für ältere
nachbarn mit einem anruf bei der familie
vielleicht gerade bei denen mit denen
wir sonst nur selten sprechen mit einer
gute-nacht-geschichte für die enkel
übers telefon mit karten oder briefen
für unsere lieben in pflegeheimen die
man jetzt nicht besuchen darf wir können
die vielen ideen und plattformen nutzen
die jetzt im internet entstehen für
freiwillige die zb den bauern bei der
ernte helfen wollen für gläubige deren
gemeindeleben jetzt online weitergehen
kann oder für sporttrainer oder hebammen
die ihre kurse per video anbieten wollen
wir können auch unseren lieblings läden
die derzeit geschlossen bleiben müssen
gutscheine abkaufen oder in unseren
lieblingsrestaurants essen zum mitnehmen
bestellen und wir können das geld für
gekaufte eintrittskarten nicht
zurückfordern
denn viele kulturschaffende deren kunst
uns gerade jetzt so viel bedeutet sind
gerade jetzt in ihrer existenz bedroht
all das und noch mehr können wir heute
ganz konkret füreinander tun
die ärztin claudia meister die in diesen
tagen in einem mobilen corona test.de
mithilft erzählt er lachend am telefon
diese krise hat auch ihr gutes jetzt
lernen wir uns alle erst so richtig
kennen sagte sie
und recht hat sie also liebe
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger wenn wir
uns jetzt so richtig kennenlernen dann
zeigen wir einander doch das beste in
uns zeigen wir mit menschlichkeit zeigen
wir solidarität wenn wir das miteinander
schaffen dann zerfällt unsere
gesellschaft nicht in dieser krise
sondern im gegenteil dann wächst
sie enger zusammen allen die helfen sage
ich von ganzem herzen danke alles gute
und geben wir acht aufeinander